do you feel like as
a member of the lgbtq community
transgenderism would you would you drop
the T from the acronym that's what I
want to ask like do you think as a
gender identity it should be included in
the same community group as sexual
orientation
um okay so I uh
I'm probably gonna I don't know I'm
probably gonna get in hot water for
saying this but like I have always been
I would say an advocate for what I
consider to be a legitimate transgender
people people gender dysphoria who
actually transition from male to female
female to male
um and I have absolutely my personal
policy is I have no trouble using the
pronouns of some if a male becomes a
female a female becomes a male I'll do
Shield I don't care I just I have a
problem with the Spectrum I will not do
they them pronouns I won't do it I don't
I will not accept
non-binaryism as a legitimate thing I
will not accept Quint genderqueer gender
fluid as a legitimate thing I just want
I I believe it's a um you know an
identity uh that somebody might just
feel like you know that's but it's it's
not a real thing and I'm not going to
participate in it
it's become harder and harder for me to
defend the transgender Community as the
transgender Community has become more
and more absurd and caricaturish and
insane and what have you like a couple
of years ago there were other gay
conservatives that we were kind of
debating and they were saying like we
really want to drop the T off of this
and I was like come on you guys like
it's like why create this because there
are transgender people in the world who
like you were kind of saying earlier
just want to live their lives and be
left alone I don't want to participate
in hurting those people and I feel like
it just hurts people to be like you're
not a party you used to be but now
you're not
um but it's getting harder and harder it
really is I mean even for like the
people that I consider to be
legitimately transgender because
they're so lost in this mess at this
point I'm sorry this you just wanted an
answer to your question no it's great um
I hate the queue don't accept the cue at
100 let's let's cut the queue off and
get rid of it a thousand percent
um I guess I'm not there yet with the
tea
um I I accept the argument that it's a
totally different thing
um you know a person's gender identity
is not the same thing as their sexual
orientation I accept that I guess the
reason why for me it was never really
like a thing that I felt the need to
make a clear line of delineation is that
I think that most or many gay people
have experienced some form of gender
dysphoria in their life I did I mean
when I was a little boy and I didn't
understand complex human sexuality
for me the feelings that I was
experiencing as a little boy it was
easier to Ida to
um to accept those feelings in terms of
gender so I knew I was a little boy who
had crushes on little boys I knew that I
liked things that little girls liked I
would have much I would have been much
happier playing with the girls than out
you know roughing it up with the boys
and fighting and things like that I
would have rather been inside playing
with Barbies
and so I kind of identify with what that
feels like to feel like you're a boy who
identifies with girls and then at a
certain point I did grow out of it and I
probably at puberty and then I realized
that I was a gay
guy a gay man
um but but I guess the point is that I
can identify with that feeling enough
that I don't feel the need to ostracize
people who are like that I feel like
some people don't grow out of that and
for them a gender transition is the
right answer to feel like they are
legitimately who they are and I I guess
I just don't see the need to ostracize
those people from the community because
I sort of understand I can relate to
that feeling it sounds like if you were
a little kid today you would end up
getting the hormone blockers and the
surgery yeah probably they put you
through it I mean if I had had
um you know parents and teachers who
wanted to embrace what I was going
through and say you know we we feel like
you know we want to
validate what you're feeling yeah things
could have gone horribly wrong it's
crazy because it's actually a very very
fundamentalist view of how to deal with
the issue of gender dysphoria so they're
doing it wrong in Iran if you're a gay
man they they give you a forced sex
change operation that's my understanding
and so what's Happening Now is really
interesting because they're going to
little kids who like social things hey
look boys can play with dolls girls can
play football right that's no big deal
well not anymore if you're a little girl
who wants to play football they will
tell you you are trans and you need the
surgery that's a really weird thing I
can't just be a woman who plays football
I don't know what's what's that exactly
well and that was what I was very poorly
articulating a moment ago when I was
talking about like that the identity
quotient of being non-binary or gender
fluid I mean I was a kid of the 80s and
in the 80s we had uh Boy George you know
we had Billy Idol we had all those hair
bands and all the people wearing makeup
and it was just sort of an expression
that's the word I think I was looking
for it was an expression not an identity
and everyone accepted that expression I
mean I'm sure there were some people who
didn't you know had an issue with Boy
George or whatever but for the most part
people like they didn't really care yeah
but now people like Oh Boy George you
need to be trans yeah you said this
before that they the party that is
advocating for you know transition
people earlier and earlier or the same
party that's saying like don't believe
gender stereotypes and give your
daughters Tonka trucks and whatever else
except if your son reaches for a Barbie
then maybe you should be on alert for
perhaps they are puberty blockers maybe
your son socially likes to hang out with
girls and who knows why that is they're
they're young well he said like I think
there's so much rush to say like we're
gonna make these kids change and
identify because we're we're trying to
protect them we're trying to help them
and like I want to believe that's Arnold
but like it has some intense
consequences for something that you
wouldn't do if in other circumstances
right but here's where I separate from
from some people on the right on this
issue because I the left has gone way
too far way way way too far and so I do
understand that there is a bit of I
would say an over correction on the
right but I hear some people on the
right say you know uh like no children
are transgender and no child is born in
the wrong body and I'm like well then
where did all these transgender adults
come from I mean we definitely know that
there are people in the world who
believe that their gender transition was
the right choice for them and that they
finally feel like who they authentically
are after they transition those people
were children at one point I'm not
saying that you should transition a
child but I'm saying transgender adults
were once transgender children so that
it really kind of can't be true you know
that's uh uh male grip strength has
dropped by what like 80 70 percent since
uh World War II
I think the the embracing of plastics
probably resulted in a rapid decline in
testosterone and a massive disruption of
the human endocrine system resulting in
Weak and effeminate and masculine weak
and feminine males and masculinized
females so one of the reasons I think we
may be seeing this big burst is the the
expansive use of plastics which we use
for all of our food and then we eat it
women get pregnant and then eat Plastics
which disrupt the endocrine systems of
the babies there were some studies that
um
we've talked about on the show before a
birth control that women were taking and
then when they got pregnant later it
would masculine masculinize the babies
and they tracked the women who got
pregnant and found that like an
overwhelming majority of their daughters
were lesbians
looking at a study like that I'm like
there's probably a correlation between
the things we are putting in our bodies
that we know are endocrine disruptors
and the expansive increase in the lgbtq
community
but yeah the problem is well that in
predatory teachers no that's for sure
you know telling kids things that they
shouldn't be teaching them but I do
think endocrine disruptors are playing a
huge role and the problem is
when a human being is affected in this
way and then they become an adult who
can vote they vote in favor of the way
they've been affected so if there is
something that is damaging and poisonous
to us and then people vote to affirm
that thing well you're gonna get more of
it could you imagine if people were
voting to affirm mesothelioma like it
was a good thing and exposing kids to
asbestos pulverized asbestos so that we
could explain you know so what was the
big deal maybe they'll get mesothelioma
too it's like look if there's an
environmental Factor that's causing harm
to people and creating depression and
anxiety we don't want to affirm that we
want to stop it and figure out what's
causing it right I think two big
components one the social component
obviously we're talking about but I do
think that phthalates pcbs Etc
chemicals in the water and the food are
causing a lot of it as well so in that
scenario then you believe that some that
a good portion of these people are
actually experiencing oh yeah gender
dysphoria yeah we we've had this
discussion that's why it's so funny when
these like these cultists lie about what
I believe
and say like denying the existence of
trans people and I'm like I'm the one
who's actually argued to many of these
uh activists like with James Lindsay for
instance saying no I think some kids are
trans I think they are kids who are born
to mothers who are taking some kind of
medication or sensitive to certain
phthalates pcbs what is it polychloral
biphenols or whatever and thus the child
in the womb was their endocrine system
got erupted in utero and in development
and then this kid is born with a more
feminized men you know brain and mental
state or or endocrine system and a
masculine body and that's going to
create dysphoria that makes perfect
sense I don't understand and and it's a
societal problem it's it's a it's a
poison that we've introduced into our
food supply that we need to deal with I
don't understand what has to be one or
the other or absolute a zero-sum game so
there are people like no no kid feels
this way it's not possible and I'm like
I think a lot of little girls are being
socially manipulated yeah and it's
because of Instagram and other social
media platforms that they're feeling
this pressure to fit in so they're
saying things they don't understand
because I've heard so many stories from
parents who are like my daughter said
that they were gay or pan or lesbian and
they're like my nine-year-old I don't
even know those words meant right but
then you're actually going to get
genuinely in my opinion more young boys
and girls who are legitimately trans and
experiencing dysphoria that doesn't mean
the treatment is surgery sterilization
or puberty blockers I don't know what
the treatment is but I certainly think
there may be a physiological effect it's
not just social
and it may pass for a lot of people well
we know that depending on the studies
you look at it's from like 65 to 90 some
odd percent that children desist and
once they have puberty they stop having
these feelings so if that's the case
shouldn't we we should absolutely lean
in that direction like let's not use
puberty blockers because most these kids
are going to be totally fine once they
they pass puberty why create more stress
and anxiety for them it's a trolley
problem
no in one way because if you if you the
argument that they make on the left is
oh if we don't have these get kids to
transition they're going to kill
themselves but if you if you transition
kids that don't need to be transitioned
and you do it and mass because of social
contagion you're going to end up
transitioning kids that you need end up
transitioning way more people than you
need and you're going to end up having
more people with ruined lives than if
you don't transition the few actual
people that are trans that after puberty
end up being actually trans the the the
high probability is that athletes most
people that feel like they're Trans in
puberty once they go through puberty
they they it desists and stops that's
the the most likely course of action
that's most likely what's going to
happen so if you if you
push everybody that has any kind of
gender dysphoria into transitioning
you're going to end up hurting a lot
more people than you help thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time